que je vous parlais d'un choeur
exceptionnel c'est le premier choeur de
jeunes filles françaises à chanter et à
donner une tournée de concerts en chine
c'est incroyable regardez ces quelques
images on en parlait avec les jeunes
filles et le chef de choeur qui est avec
nous aujourd'hui
[Musique]
oui
et
moi
[Musique]
et
non
oui
si vous nous rejoignez ce n'est pas un
extrait d'un film que vous avez
probablement tous vu les choristes quand
il s'agit bien d'une troupe d'un coeur
de chez nous dont vous êtes le chef de
choeur
hugo qui tirait ça s'appelle lumina che
l'exacte mans et et ses deux jeunes
filles nous ont rejoints par ce qu'elles
en font partie bonjour marie lou bonjour
et bonjour agathe on peut se tutoyer
oui ouais super bon le patron c'est hugo
1 c'est ça un bon il est gentil rigaux
super parlez-moi de cette chorale que
vous dirigez finalement vous l'ancien
chef de choeur des petits chanteurs à la
croix de bois quand même pour mettre un
peu le niveau lui également également
alors je vais reconstitue raconter un
peu l'histoire de cette maîtrise avant
pour comprendre alors moi ce que je
voudrais savoir ce qu'est ce que c'est
que l'on me lâcher ni surtout qu'elle
n'a pas d'odeur non alors voilà oui
alors c'est un choeur de jeunes filles
fondée en 2012 que j'ai fondée en 2012
au sein de la maîtrise de la cathédrale
d'autun dont je suis le directeur et qui
a un projet artistique de deux coeurs de
cathédrale avec cette particularité de
n'être composé que de jeunes filles de
10 à 6 à 16 ans donc on doit gagner vous
qui sont exactement
voilà donc à que des jeunes filles dans
ce coeur si particulier voilà qui est
donc le premier je le disais en france
est l'un des rares aussi à rayonner à
l'international en tout cas ça sera la
première fois que un corps comme le
vôtre partira faire une grande grande
tournée en chine voilà dans des grandes
salles des grandes philharmonie concerto
le en chine dans les grandes capitales
de province pour qu'on soit bien clair
c'est une école maîtrisienne c'est l'une
des très rares en bourgogne franche
comté je crois qu'il n'y en a que trois
pour être très précis à dijon
châlon-sur-saône exactement est la vôtre
donc on l'a compris du côté de là où
vous vous trouvez à autun c'est pas une
chorale academy c'est quoi parce que une
chorale academy b fait une école
maîtrise nc ou au sein du parcours
scolaire intégrer à leurs cours ils ont
leur formation artistique c'est à dire
technique vocale le solfège chant choral
voilà il faut bien qu'on comprenne
comment se passent vos journées qui
raconte et - paris jean marie le raconte
moi comment se passe ta journée
il ya une partie scolaire une partie
chorale chanson voilà en fait
souvent le soir deux heures de maîtrise
après les cours et c'est directement
rattaché au cours ce qui nous permet de
pouvoir sortir à une heure raisonnable
d'accord tant que classe quatrième les
toits goethe
alors moi je suis au lycée ça a un peu
changé pour moi cette année et une
grande alors donc mais j'ai toujours mes
heures de maîtrise j'ai un peu un peu
plus de travail au lycée et donc je vais
à la maîtrise le samedi matin
la com pure classe second super comment
vous vous effectuez vos entraînements
toutes les deux est ce qu'on fait à
l'entraînement
marie l'eau en fait née répartis en
plusieurs coeurs donc enfin en plusieurs
coeurs donc mais il ya un autre coeur
principal filon qu'avec tout le monde
toutes les filles les primaires les
collégiennes et lycéennes
on est souvent en réunit toutes ensemble
et voilà mais parce qu'il faut bien
qu'on comprenne hugo et à deux coeurs il
y a on va dire le le premier cup qui
s'appelle le coeur préparatoire
justement où sont les élèves du primaire
puis ensuite le coeur principal composé
du collège et du lycée
donc pour entrer dans le coeur principal
il faut avoir parcouru et valider toutes
les enseignements qui a eu aux primaires
mais on peut rentrer également au
collège mais il faut valider certains
certaine
justement comment on y rentre c'est quoi
ces castings ces auditions ces
immersions commencé voilà ça allait
rejoindre l'école voilà alors ce n'est
pas c'est pas
auditions dans le sens où vous
convaincre la personne qui passe des
examens et des concours c'est une
immersion pendant un certain temps et
l'enfant ensuite la jeune fille qui est
la voix si elle peut poursuivre avec
nous ce parcours qui est quand même
assez lourds avec toutes ces heures de
chant et oui c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on
comprenne agathe comment ça se passe
pour toi comment tu arrives à tout gérer
finalement peu de temps alors en fait on
a beaucoup de concerts et de
d'intervention donc ça c'est les
week-ends c'est vrai que ça prend du
temps mais on aime on aime faire ça donc
ça nous dérange pas et ensuite l'école
il suffit de bien s'avancer et ensuite
ensuite ces longs mois la vie de tournée
c'est particulièrement grisant
vous n'êtes pas trop angoissé toutes les
deux marie lou et la gueule petit peu
quand même
oui parce que partir en chine partez
combien de temps en chine une quinzaine
de jours vous vous êtes préparés comme
en beaucoup travaillé ce bois illégaux
qui se rit c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
de travail
vous êtes qu'elle voit vous soprano
mezzo alto vous êtes quoi voit toutes
les deux une machine tout d'accord mais
c'est se prennent au quai comment on
arrive à faire un coeur comme ça à faire
toutes ces voix qui se marient et rigaux
alors d'abord il faut les auditionner
alors il faut savoir quelque chose de
très important dans cette un coeur qui a
quatre pupitres un pupille de soprano a
beaucoup plus léger pointue avec des
voies plus jeune et fraîche un pupitre
de soprano 2 un peu plus large
ensuite arrivent les mezzo soprano et
les altos donc les filles sont
régulièrement auditionné pour savoir
dans quel pitre elles vont être parce
que leurs cordes vocales change évoluer
oui j'allais le dire et avec la
vaisselle alors il n'y a pas la mieux
comme chez les garçons mais plus jeune
fille grandisse et puis leur timbre
change et s'élargissent donc pour
obtenir le timbre précis que l'on
souhaite
je préfère maintenir pour avoir cette
couleur des timbres plus étroit plus
pointues dans les aigus et on élargit la
base ensuite pour la tournée en chine
vous avez choisi vivaldi un petit peu
comme à l'origine finalement en quelques
mots qu'est ce que vous pouvez me dire
pour ceux qui connaissent parce que bon
on pense aux quatre saisons mais a pas
que les quatre saisons alors hilaliens a
beaucoup écrit pour les voit
effectivement aujourd'hui on chante ses
oeuvres à voix mixtes avec des hommes
chantent les voix de basse et ténor
vivaldi dirigeait également un choeur de
jeunes filles à venise
et avait écrit pour sucker alors j'ai
fait ce travail ne suis pas le seul à le
faire de reconstitution des oeuvres
chanter à voix égales pour un choeur de
voix de jeunes filles de 10 à 16 ans qui
était à peu près ce qu'avait antonio
vivaldi à son époque
en tout cas on retiendra que c'est le
premier coeur de jeune fille française a
donné une tournée de concerts en chine
on a de quoi être fier c'est lumina
cheli vous venez d'autun vous reste avec
nous